sono qui per raccontarvi la storia del
grande ero plano che vedete alle mie
spalle
siamo nel primo dopoguerra e il suo
progettista gianni caproni come tanti
imprenditori dell'epoca si trovavano le
necessità di convertire l'attività delle
sue aziende
le tende caproni durante la prima guerra
mondiale avevano prodotto grandi aerei
pluri motori impiegati come bombardieri
che alla fine del conflitto ovviamente
non servivano più
la grande intuizione l'ingegner caproni
fu quella di capire che grandi aeroplani
potevano essere impiegati per il
trasporto di tanti passeggeri su lunghe
distanze in concorrenza ai piroscafi
dell'epoca fu il primo ad avere questa
intuizione e così nel 1919 fu avviata la
costruzione di un imponente idrovolante
talmente grande da guadagnarsi il
soprannome di palazzo con le ali
lo vedete qui alle mie spalle un
aeroplano di tre piani
un'idea grandiosa potremmo dire il primo
jumbo jet della storia
per capirci il primo aeroplano della
storia quello dei fratelli wright che
oggi abbiamo già nominato che
sicuramente conoscete tutti
aveva un lato meno di vent'anni prima e
quindi nel 1919 pensare un aeroplano in
grado di trasportare fino a 100
passeggeri seduti lo vedete l'interno
che alle mie spalle
era un'idea di una lungimiranza
straordinaria forse eccessiva furono
infatti molti quelli che mossero contro
caproni criticandolo aspramente la sua
idea ritenendola inattuabile in quanto
troppo audace caro caproni scriveva in
un memoriale un importante personaggio
che durante la prima guerra mondiale
aveva condiviso con l'ingegnere l'idea
dell'impiego della rope lana per il
dominio dell'area caro caproni in
passato hai fatto sicuramente cose
grandiose ma su questa cosa qui mi
dispiace ti sbagli il futuro del
trasporto passeggeri non può prevedere
porto di tante persone molto lontano e
magari anche più velocemente dei
piroscafi e l'ingegner caproni vi
starete domandando come reagiva tutte
queste critiche
lui andava avanti aveva un sogno non
voleva realizzare ed era convinto della
sua idea nonostante diversi momenti di
sconforto e soprattutto era consapevole
del fatto che se il suo grande
apparecchio avesse volato avrebbe
cambiato la storia del trasporto
passeggeri per sempre lo doveva
all'umanità questo grande passaggio è il
4 marzo 1921 è tutto pronto all'hangar
di sesto calende sul lago maggiore
ed è un giorno talmente importante
caproni ne è consapevole che scrittura
un fotografo e un regista perché
documenti in ogni istante della prova di
volo vi dirò di più nella sua testa e
nei suoi diari caproni scrive che vuole
usare le fotografie e il girato per la
reclame del suo aeroplano sulle riviste
nelle sale cinematografiche è tutto
pronto il 4 marzo 1921 all'hangar di
sesto calende sul lago maggiore
ma l'ingegnere non si vede dove è
l'ingegnere è andato a milano a prendere
il regista che ha avuto un problema con
la macchina e ha lasciato un ordine di
non decollare fino al suo ritorno ma
federico semprini il pilota collaudatore
designato non sta più nella pelle sono
mesi che aspetta quel momento e quindi
pensa per ingannare l'attesa di
effettuare intanto una prova di
flottaggio tranquilli significa una
corsa lungo il lago senza decollare
l'aveva fatta diverse volte prima e
quindi fa calare il grande aeroplano il
lago accende i motori e comincia la sua
corsa
via via più veloce quasi 110 chilometri
all'ora
va tutto bene quando a un certo punto
mentre sta pilotando scorge un qualche
cosa
all'orizzonte prima un puntino nero poi
via via capisce di che cosa si tratta un
vaporetto di quelli che portavano la
gente da una sponda all'altra del lago
ed è esattamente in rotta di collisione
non c'è tempo per pensare all'ordine
l'ingegnere di non decollare fino al suo
ritorno
bisogna evitare l'impatto
e in un attimo il grande ero plano punta
la prua verso l'alto
è un attimo dopo la punta verso il basso
il vaporetto è stato scavalcato
l'aeroplano andato distrutto nel suo
diario di quel giorno
caproni scriverà tutto è perso in un
momento ma se si vuole progredire
occorre non lasciarsi abbattere da
quanto accaduto perché la strada del
progresso è disseminata di sofferenza
nel leggere queste parole ho sempre
provato un'emozione fortissima e mi sono
domandata che cosa avesse permesso a
caproni di non arrendersi di continuare
a guardare al futuro con fiducia
pensate cosa sarebbe stato il trasporto
passeggeri o anche solo la sua carriera
se si fosse arreso dopo il fallimento
del palazzo con le ali la risposta che
mi sono data è che caproni avesse
imparato a costruire sui suoi fallimenti
questo ma soprattutto uno precedente
il primo il più importante lasciate che
vi racconti anche questa storia
siamo nel 1910 quando gianni caproni il
fratello federico e alcuni amici
provenienti da arco si trasferiscono in
brughiera lombarda per insediare lì la
loro attività di costruzione
chiude di apparecchi volanti prendono
alloggio uomini e mezzi all'interno di
un hangar in legno appoggiata una
cascina di nome malpensa e sul hangar
fanno scrivere orgogliosamente hangar
ingegner gianni caproni fa niente se
quando piove o nevica e il tra acqua dal
tetto e devono ripararsi sotto le ali
degli aeroplani fa niente se sotto il
letto
cresce letteralmente l'erba fa niente se
per procurarsi il cibo devono fare ogni
volta oltre una dozzina di km in
bicicletta quei giovani pionieri sono
pieni di speranza fermamente convinti
del motto che volere è potere e quindi
tutti vinciam p che via via gli si
parano davanti nemmeno rivedono e ad
onor del vero vincenti in quei primi tre
anni di attività
se ne presentano parecchi anzitutto
l'esercito dal quale avevano ottenuto
langar di cui vi ho parlato che dopo
pochi mesi rivuole langar e il campo di
fronte e caproni armi e bagagli e si
trasferisce dall'altra parte del campo
trovando un altro hangar dove alloggiare
uomini e mezzi e poi i soldi che
mancavano sistematicamente e qualunque
prenditore sa che senza soldi è
difficile fare affari e caproni cosa fa
trova prima un socio con il quale
mettersi in affari che dopo pochi mesi
lo abbandona poi ne trova un altro che
lo abbandona e poi ne trova un altro
ancora che lo abbandona avanti così tre
anni di speranze e disillusioni in un
circolo vizioso difficile da rompere
senza soldi non si possono comperare i
motori da mettere sugli aeroplani da
vendere ma se non si vendono agli
aeroplani
non ci sono i soldi per comperare i
motori da mettere sugli a locali da
vendere
semplice e così nella primavera del 1913
caproni si trova di fronte la decisione
difficile della sua vita fino a quel
momento lo scriverà nel suo diario e lo
sottolinea in rosso
medito lasciare aviazione e di lì a poco
accetterà di vendere le sue aziende allo
stato per restarne soltanto direttore
tecnico sembra la fine di tutto si
rivelerà essere l'inizio
certo fu la fine di una prima fase
dell'attività produttiva delle aziende
caproni che coincise però con una
seconda e più importante parabola
evolutiva che vedrà alla fine della
grande guerra caprone produrrano klami
addirittura negli stati uniti fine e
inizio come due facce di una stessa
medaglia è solo una questione di
prospettiva questa parte della storia
personale umana di caproni professionale
e umana di capra che mi ha sempre
colpito perché credo che ciascuno di noi
attraverso nella vita momenti in cui
mette in discussione la correttezza del
volo che sta compiendo la grandezza di
caprone in quelle circostanze fu quella
di saper adattare gli obiettivi ai cambi
di rotta che erano intervenuti caproni
era un talentuoso visionario un
inguaribile sognatore ma soprattutto era
un uomo dotato di magistrale e capacità
di resilienza e il suo talento poté
davvero decollare soltanto quando fu
libero dal pensiero di trovare i soldi
per poter costruire gli aeroplani che in
realtà aveva ancora soltanto in testa a
caproni a tutti i sognatori si deve il
coraggio di non essersi arresi perché
dopo di loro quello che prima era
soltanto un sogno anche se una volta
hanno fallito dopo è diventato possibile
se avete un sogno e ci credete veramente
forse con qualche aggiustamento di rotta
lo potete anche realizzare grazie
[Applauso]